bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de la plus belle expérience de toute la
physique en tout cas celle qui a été
élue comme tel en 2002 par les lecteurs
du magazine physique sword
il s'agit d'une expérience spectaculaire
emblématique de la mécanique quantique
une expérience que le grand physicien
richard feynman utilisait déjà dans les
années 60 de façon fameuse pour
enseigner son célèbre cours sur le sujet
et pourtant cette expérience personne ne
l'a jamais vraiment fait jusqu'à il ya
seulement quelques années pour
comprendre l'histoire de cette
expérience il faut remonter à la fin du
xviie siècle
à cette époque deux grands physiciens
s'affrontaient pour comprendre la nature
profonde de la lumière
le célèbre isaac newton était persuadé
que la lumière était faite de
corpuscules de particules tandis que le
néerlandais christiaan huygens lui était
convaincu que la lumière était une onde
la question n'a en fait pas été tranchée
de leur vivant et beaucoup pensaient que
c'était newton qui avait raison parce
que newton quoi jusqu'en 1820 presque un
siècle plus tard ou un autre physicien
thomass yong a mis fin au débat avec une
expérience faisant intervenir une double
fente et pour comprendre pourquoi une
double fente
on va commencer par des choses simples
imaginez une planche de bois dans
laquelle on a percé une fente de
quelques centimètres
un peu comme une meurtrière si vous
voulez et derrière laquelle se trouve un
mur est supposé que vous tiriez sur la
planche avec une mitraillette
alors comme vous savez pas très très
bien visé un certain nombres des balles
se retrouve arrêté par la planche tandis
que le reste passe par la fente et va se
loger dans le mur et sur ce mur l'impact
de l'ensemble des balles forme une tâche
allongé qui reproduit à peu près la
forme de la fente normal maintenant
imaginez que dans la planche il y ait
deux fentes assez proches l'une de
l'autre et que vous tiriez dans leur
direction
eh bien elle va se passer la même chose
un sauf que les impacts formeront cette
fois deux tâches allongés côte à côte
la tâche de gauche correspondant aux
balles passées par la fente de gauche
est pareil à droite
alors tout ça vous semble certainement
parfaitement évident mais maintenant
imaginons que l'on fasse la même
expérience non pas avec des balles de
mitraillette mais avec des ondes
autour de nous il existe plein dont d'un
les ondes radios ou les ondes sonores
les micro ondes etc mais sont pas
forcément simple à se représenter alors
on va prendre un autre type d'onde que
tout le monde connaît les vagues
pour être honnête sur le plan physique
les vagues ne sont pas les ongles et
plus simple qui soit mais pour notre
visualisation ça va suffire
imaginez donc une série de vagues qui se
propage à la surface de l'eau pour
étudier ce phénomène de façon contrôlée
j'ai utilisé un petit montage
expérimental qu'on appelle une cuve à
monde
une cuve annoncé une sorte de bac à fond
transparent dans lequel on peut verser
une faible épaisseur dos et qui est muni
d'un système d'éclairage stroboscopique
et d'un miroir de façon à pouvoir
visualiser les ondes sur un écran sauf
qu ici plutôt que de faire des vagues à
la main j'ai utilisé une petite barre
qui vibre et qui créent des ondes en
surface et j'éteins la lumière ambiante
pour mieux voir l'écran voilà ce qu'on
observe alors comme je suis pas super
bon pour faire des expériences 1 pour
compléter j'ai fait aussi une petite
simulation numérique
cette simulation le permet de calculer
la propagation des vagues et représente
le même genre de choses ici c'est une
vue de dessus quand ces sombres c'est un
creux de la vague et quand c'est clair
c'est un sommet ont maintenant la
question c'est qu'est ce qui se passe si
je balance une onde de ce genre à
travers une fente
voici une forme placé sur le chemin de
mon nom d'un intuitivement on pourrait
penser qu'il va se passer ça et ben
essayons avec la cuvée ronde
j'ai placé un obstacle avec une petite
fente au milieu
[Musique]
et voilà ce qu'on observe on constate
que derrière la fente l'on devient
circulaire et on retrouve évidemment la
même chose en plus visible si on fait
tourner ma simulation ça c'est un
phénomène qu'on appelle la diffraction
on peut parfois l'observé avec des
vraies vagues sur des photos google
earth de bord de mer comme ici c'est le
port d'alexandrie bien maintenant
refusons la même expérience mais cette
fois avec deux fentes dans la cuve à
monde j'ai placé un obstacle avec deux
ouvertures et comme on pouvait s'y
attendre on observe eu de zone
circulaire qui émerge de chacune des
fentes sauf que dans la zone où les
ondes se rencontrent il se passe un truc
étrange ça se voit mieux sur la
simulation regarder imaginez je me
trouve ici un sur l'axé central à cet
endroit les deux ondes que je reçois
s'ajoutent les deux sommets se cumulent
et forme un sommet plus élevés et
inversement juste après les deux creux
coïncident et ainsi de suite
globalement en ce point on a des vagues
dont l'amplitude est doublé
mais si je me déplace un tout petit peu
ici vous voyez que je suis plus près
d'une forte que de l'autre et les deux
on arrive donc décalé l'une par rapport
à l'autre et à cet endroit le creux de
la première ronde coïncide avec le
sommet de la seconde et réciproquement
et du coup les deux ondes ce qu'on pense
exactement
vous voyez que pile à cet endroit là ça
ne bouge pas l'amplitude des vagues nuls
en fait y'a pas de vague et on trouve
bien ça dans l'expérience de la q1
regarder dans ces zones
ici on n'a pas de vagues les deux ondes
ce qu'on pense tout ça forme un
phénomène qu'on appelle des
interférences et quand on regarde de
plus près on voit qu'on a une succession
de zones où les ondes s'ajoutent et ou
au contraire elle se compensent
si on s'amuse à tracer l'amplitude des
vagues en fonction de la position ici on
a une oscillation de ce genre
[Musique]
cette figure d'interférences qu'on
obtient quand une onde rencontre une
double fente est donc très différent de
ce qu'on avait avec des balles de
mitraillette où on avait deux zones bien
localiser les interférences sont un
phénomène typique des ondes
alors comme je vous disais au début en
1801 tomassian que s'intéresse donc au
débat sur la nature de la lumière ondes
ou particules et il se demande ce qui se
passe quand on fait justement passer de
la lumière par une double feinte alors
l'époque il l'avait fait que la lumière
du soleil mais ce qu'une expérience
qu'on peut refaire plus facilement
aujourd'hui avec un laser
ici j'ai placé un laser rouge dont on a
élargi un peu le faisceau et sa lumière
arrive sur ces deux minuscules france
qui sont très rapprochées 1 le tout fait
moins d'un millimètre de large et voici
ce que j'ai obtenu sur l'écran situé un
peu plus loin des belles interférences
on n'a pas du tout deux tâches comme on
aurait avec des projectiles mais quelque
chose de typique d'une onde et c'est
avec une expérience de ce genre que yong
conclu que la lumière est donc une onde
est que ces huygens qui avait raison
enfin provisoirement à ce stade de la
vidéo vous êtes est l'impression que
vous êtes fait avoir je vous ai promis
de la mécanique quantique et pour
l'instant je vous parle de vague et de
querelles de physiciens du 17e alors
rentrons dans le vif du sujet à votre
avis qu'est ce qui se passe si on fait
l'expérience de la double fente avec des
électrons
[Musique]
la première chose qu'il faut dire c'est
qu'on sait faire l'équivalent d'une
mitraillette à électrons un canon à
électrons c'est le principe du tube
cathodique
vous savez celui qu'on trouve dans les
vieilles télés dont les écrans sont pas
plat du tout pour faire un tube
cathodique on prend un filament par
exemple de tungstène qu'on chauffe avec
un courant électrique comme dans une
ampoule le filament va alors émettre des
électrons avec un voltage élevé on peut
alors créer un champ électrique qui va
accélérer ses électrons et les envoyer
dans une certaine direction et on prend
soin de mettre tout ça sous vide dans un
tube pour voir les électrons on peut
placer une substance phosphorescente à
l'extrémité du tube et on verra alors
des taches lumineuses laissés par les
électrons qui l'atteignent
c'est le principe de l'écran cathodique
et c'est d'ailleurs avec une expérience
de ce genre qu'un autre physicien
thompson a pu montrer à la fin du 19ème
que les électrons était bien des
particules et qu'on pouvait dévier leurs
trajectoires et comme ça il a même
appris des choses sur leur masse et leur
charge électrique bien donc on sait
faire à cannes en électrons et ben
balance on s'assure une double fente en
mettant derrière un écran phosphorescent
et voyons ce qu'on obtient et bien si
vous faisiez cette expérience voilà ce
que vous observerez y est c'est bizarre
non on n'a pas du tout deux tâches comme
avec des balles de mitraillette mais une
alternance de bandes noires et blanches
qui rappelle quand même furieusement des
interférences qu'est ce qui se passe
pourquoi est ce qu'on n'obtient pas la
même chose qu'avec les balles de
mitraillette c'est-à-dire deux tâches
pour un truc qu'on peut se dire pour
essayé de l'expliquer c'est qu'on n'est
quand même pas tout à fait dans la même
situation
déjà la mitraillette tire les balles une
par une alors que là il ya certainement
une quantité énorme d'électrons qui sont
émis tous en même temps
et puis les balles une fois en vol on
sait qu'elle s'influencent pas les unes
les autres
par contre les électrons ce sont des
particules chargées donc on pourrait
imaginer qu'ils interagissent entre eux
au cours de leur trajectoire
par exemple qui se repoussent par
endroits où bien qu'il existe une force
qui nous échappe qu'il ait des vies pour
provoquer cette figure pourquoi pas pour
tester ça on peut faire une chose c'est
baisser la fréquence de tir du canon un
électron pour envoyer les électrons un
parent de telle sorte qu'un électron et
le temps d'arriver sur l'écran avant que
le suivant soit émis et là il se passe
un truc de malade
si on tire les électrons un par un on
constate effectivement que chacun
provoque une tache lumineuse sur l'écran
sauf que peu à peu on voit se construire
une alternance de bandes claires et
sombres
les électrons un parent viennent former
des interférences en tirant comme ça les
électrons individuellement on peut
difficilement soutenir qui s'influencent
entre eux pour venir former des
interférences pour essayer d'y voir plus
clair un truc qu'on peut faire c'est
d'essayer de comprendre sur cette figure
quels sont les électrons passer par la
première feinte et par la seconde est ce
qu'à droite ce sont les électrons passer
par la femme de droite et à gauche par
la forme de gauche a pour ça il ya une
façon simple de procéder
il suffit de boucher alternativement une
fente puis l'autre pour obtenir les deux
parties de la figure si on n'ouvre
qu'une seule des deux fentes voilà le
genre de figure qu'on obtient pas
d'interférence mais une seule tâche
assez étalée est pareil si c'est l'autre
fente qu'on offre mais du coup on a un
truc complètement inattendue la la
figure avec les deux fentes ouverte
n'est pas égale à celle qu'on obtient en
additionnant les deux figures obtenu
avec une seule fente pour comprendre à
quel point ce résultat anormal
revenons au cas de la mitraillette quand
je tire sur les deux fentes chaque balle
passe soit par une forte soit par
l'autre quand une balle passe par la
fente 1 que la fente 2 soit bouché ou
paba sa charge rien et réciproquement
donc la figure qu'on obtient quand les
deux fentes sont ouvertes et bien la
somme des deux figures obtenu avec une
seule fentes et bien dans le cas des
électrons ça n'est pas le cas et ça
semble indiquer que quand un électron
passe par la fente 1 et bien son
comportement va dépendre du fait que la
fente 2 soit ouverte ou pas et l'effet
est vraiment critique puisque on a
carrément des zones de l'image qui quand
on débouche la fente deux vont devenir
plus sombre c'est à dire recevoir -
d'électrons que quand elle était fermée
et je rappelle que les électrons
arrivent un par un
ça veut dire que le point d'arrivée de
chaque électrons dépend de l'état des
deux fentes comment on peut expliquer ça
on pourra dire à la limite que quand un
électron passe par une fente et ben il
est influencé par l'état de l'autre
fente c'est à dire qu'il sait ou qu'il
sent si elle est ouverte ou fermée
une façon encore plus imagée de se le
représenter c'est de dire carrément que
quand les deux fentes sont ouvertes les
électrons passent tous par les deux
fentes à la fois après tout c'est ce que
fait une onde
et ça qui explique qu'on obtienne des
interférences là il sauf qu'un électron
c'est pas une onde c'est une particule
est une particule qui passe par deux
chemins à la fois c'est quand même un
peu difficile à avaler pour lever le
mystère on peut peut-être laissé les
deux fentes ouverte pour avoir des
interférences mais placer un détecteur
qui permettent de savoir quand même par
quelle feinte et passer chaque électrons
pour ça richard feynman a proposé
d'utiliser le fait que les électrons
diffuse la lumière c'est à dire que si
je balance une lumière intense sur un
électron et bien il va renvoyer une
partie de cette lumière dans toutes les
directions
dans notre montage on peut du coup
imaginer mettre une grosse source
lumineuse juste après les deux fentes et
des détecteurs de lumière à côté ça
permettrait alors chaque fois qu'un
électron voyage de le faire briller et
donc de révéler par quel fond il est
passé et bien si on ajoute effectivement
un tel système de détection
nouvelle surprise la figure
d'interférences disparaît on a bien les
deux fentes ouverte mais on se retrouve
seulement avec une grosse tache qui en
fait est la somme des deux qu'on a quand
on n'ouvre qu'une seule fente grâce aux
détecteurs on arrive effectivement à
dire par quel fentes et passer chaque
électrons mais du coup il ya plus
d'interférences il est impossible
d'avoir à la fois les interférences et
de savoir par quel fente passe chaque
électrons c'est l'un ou l'autre
donc non seulement les électrons semble
passer par les deux fentes à la fois
mais en plus si on essaie de savoir par
quel fond ils passent effectivement et
bien leurs comportements changent
ces expériences peut vous paraître un
peu folle et d'ailleurs c'est le cas
c'est pour ça qu'elle fascine autant les
physiciens
aujourd'hui on arrive à les interpréter
dans le cadre du formalisme de la
mécanique quantique
alors je vais évidemment pas tout vous
détailler mais je vais essayer de vous
en donner un aperçu de façon générale la
mécanique quantique nous dit que suivant
la situation
les objets quantique peuvent se
comporter comme des ondes ou comme des
particules et parfois les deux dans la
même expérience
c'est le principe de la dualité ondes
corpuscules dans notre expérience
l'électron voyage initialement comme une
onde de façon délocaliser et quand ils
traversent l'obstacle
il est donc influencé par les deux
fentes et l'ong produit des
interférences mais quand l'électron
arrive sur l'écran est bien ce dernier
fonctionne comme un détecteur de
position qui en quelque sorte le force à
se localiser dans une position précise
et donc on a un point lumineux qui
apparaît sur l'écran l'endroit exact où
apparaît ce point est aléatoire mais il
loupe
il ya une règle l'électron va se
localiser préférentiellement dans les
zones où le monde est forte
cette onde dont on parle est en fait une
onde de probabilité de présence
elle représente la probabilité de
détecter l'électron à tel ou tel endroit
et c'est pour ça qu'on a une figure d'
interférence sur l'écran les bandes
lumineuses correspondent aux zones où la
probabilité de présence est élevé et où
beaucoup d'électrons vont se localiser
tandis que les bandes sombres sont les
zones de probabilité de présence plus
faible puisque l'électron voyage comme
une onde et se localisant d'une
particule seulement une fois sur l'écran
ça traduit la nature fondamentalement
probabiliste de la mécanique quantique
ça n'est pas comme si chaque électrons
avait un trajet qui nous apparaissent
aléatoire du fait de notre ignorance
mais que dans le fond il est quand même
suivi une trajectoire bien déterminé un
nom
il passe par les deux fentes à la fois
et on a vu que si on refuse cette idée
et qu'on met un détecteur pour essayer
de révéler sa trajectoire et bien on
détruit les interférences
car on le force aussi à se localiser et
à devenir une particule si vous voulez à
ce moment-là il choisit donc un peu
aléatoirement la fente par laquelle il
est passé
c'est bizarre non cette expérience est
vraiment fabuleuse car elle nous montre
les ingrédients essentiels de la
mécanique quantique
il y à la dualité en corpuscules bien
sûr mais aussi le fait que la mécanique
quantique est fondamentalement
probabiliste et enfin cette expérience
nous montre qu'on ne peut pas observer
certains phénomènes comme par exemple la
position d'une particule sans perturber
l'expérience de façon dramatique
j'espère que vous comprenez maintenant
pourquoi cette version de l'expérience
de la double fente où on envoie les
électrons un parent est considérée comme
la plus belle de toute la physique par
beaucoup et pourtant je vous le disais
en un trou bien qu'elle soit très
populaire depuis les années 60
cette expérience n'a vraiment été
réalisé sous cette forme là qu'en 2013
et pour ceux que ça intéresse je donne
des détails dans le billet de blog qui
accompagne la vidéo
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo si vous
l'avez apprécié abonnez-vous la cloche
tout ça un merci tout particulier à
arnaud qui m'a accueilli et vraiment
bien aidé pour les expériences et
j'espère pour mettre à ça comme
d'habitude la q2 la chaîne c'est
facebook et twitter et on se retrouve
très bientôt pour des nouvelles
des eaux
[Musique]